all right so moving on
um we have two questions combined
the asker of the first question uh
we are not saying his name on the air
due to profanity because that's
something we
clearly care about on this podcast but
the question is
is fasted training and in parentheses
weightlifting ever beneficial
the second question here is from nick
nick says i train at 5 a.m and take a
protein shake prior to training
anything else or would you recommend
anything else
uh to do or eat before working out in a
fasted state
yeah so i should clarify the the first
name was
it was just very low humor very uh
toilet humor name horrible stuff i i
would have been more
likely to include genuine profanity than
that
um and what you're gonna see with my
questions for this episode is they're
they're kind of linked
i tried to arrange them in like a
step-by-step way because a lot of people
had very similar
overlapping questions so let's get
started is fasted weight lifting
ever beneficial we've talked about this
before so i don't want to reiterate
points we've made
many times before you could make an
argument
uh in some context that you would want
to do potentially some low glycogen
training or you know
do a training about when your glycogen
storage is low
but that's going to have a lot more
carry over to endurance type exercise in
terms of the
adaptations we're trying to promote with
low glycogen training
and it's important to note that low
glycogen training does not mean fasted
training necessarily
you could do it in a fasted state that
would be one way to induce
low glycogen but they're not necessarily
the same thing because honestly if you
had an
enormous carbohydrate meal before bed
and then you woke up and worked out in a
fasted state
your glycogen still probably is not
quite depleted so
there are some instances for endurance
type athletes of doing some low glycogen
training specifically
um i fail to see much of a crossover
that would justify that type of training
strategy for someone who's purely
interested in more lifting related
training so if your goals are strength
and hypertrophy
um the question then becomes can you get
away with fasted training
not would there be a benefit of of
necessarily intentionally doing it
um it's not better to do fasted
weightlifting
but there are a lot of people who need
to train very early in the morning
and for them sometimes there's a dilemma
where if i try to
get a meal in either have to wake up way
earlier than i want to
or i have to eat in very close proximity
to my workout and then my stomach hurts
during my workout and that actually
impairs my performance
so that's kind of the rare circumstance
where if the if the binary decision is i
train fasted or i have a whole meal
and the whole meal makes me so sick i
can't perform well in that instance it
might make sense to go fasted but i
think there's a comfortable middle
ground that you can achieve
and that leads me to question two of
this kind of question pairing
you know i wake up at 5am obviously i'm
not going to say well why don't you wake
up at 3 30
make a nice meal let it digest and then
90 minutes later you can go to the gym
people aren't going to do that so what
can what can you do
to try to get some decent pre-workout
nutrition
in that scenario what else would you
have besides a protein shake so
um on the supplement side of things
there are a couple pre-workout things
that might be helpful generally speaking
this isn't uh specific to people
training in the fasted state
but you know if you can get a little
caffeine dose in maybe 30 to 60 minutes
before
you know the brunt of your workout that
can give you a little boost
uh citrulline malate is usually consumed
about 60 minutes pre so if you just have
a little
caffeine and citrulline right upon
waking by the time you get to the gym
and you're really in the groove
you know you've probably got it's
probably in your system enough
to do something for you now the question
was if i have a protein shake you know
what else can i do there
before i get into other things a protein
shake is an excellent way to try to get
some nutrition in
uh that theoretically will be kind of
easy to digest
and the reason we would want some kind
of some kind of protein or amino acids
beforehand is so that
you know immediately after the workout
you've got some amino acids
in the bloodstream that can start
helping you build some muscle
now some people if they have protein
even if it's a protein shake before
training
it can be a little harsh on their
stomach and they struggle to digest it
while they're working out
so if that's you there's a few options
on the table
you might find that a hydrolyzed version
of protein is a little easier for you
than a whole protein they basically
hydrolyze some of those peptide bonds it
makes it a little bit more digestible
uh you could take it a step further and
go with an essential amino acid mixture
which i would say is probably the second
best option
and then the third best option which is
better than nothing but probably not
ideal would be would be to go with like
a branched chain amino acid
mixture so that's how i would kind of
rank your protein options
so now outside of protein what would you
want to do
i do think it's a decent idea as long as
you can afford the calories
to get some amount of carbohydrate in
that pre-training meal
for most people i say minimum of like 20
to 40-ish grams of carbs depending on
your body size
and then obviously depending on what
exactly you're doing if you're going for
a three hour run
it it's going to be more than that but
if you're going in for a 60 minute
bodybuilding workout
you can probably get away with 20 to 40
grams depending on body size
um it is interesting when you look at
the pre-exercise
carbohydrate literature there are a
couple really interesting things
to at least at least mention
so there's some research showing that
even a glucose mouth rinse
has improved some aspects of performance
and most of those studies are looking at
moderate to higher intensity endurance
type training for the most part
and there are some mixed results some
studies show a benefit some studies show
no benefit
but it is an interesting thing that
likely
currently the the uh the line of
thinking is that
there's some kind of central mechanism
that you have receptors
in the oral cavity that can sense that
glucose
and they trigger parts of the brain
associated with like motivation and
reward
and that that uh has a central effect on
on allowing you to
perform better and exercise there there
are studies though
that fail to show that um i know um
tromalin how does he say his his first
name i think it's yours
so he actually sent me a copy of his
dissertation
uh recently and i haven't read through
the whole thing
because it's kind of long i i feel like
you put a lot of work into it
if i'm being honest it's really good
though no it's it's exceptional
yeah really really good work um but one
of his studies was on a glucose mouth
rinse and they found no benefit
either in the fasted or the fed state if
i recall correctly
but in any case it's an interesting
thing about pre-workout carbohydrate
considerations the other
interesting consideration is something
called rebound hypoglycemia
and this is something that i believe the
initial studies that got big were done
in the 70s
and what they found was they gave people
this pre-workout
carbohydrate about 45 to 60 minutes
before the onset of exercise and what
happened was
you know this high carbohydrate meal
they would have blood glucose and
insulin initially go up and then
they would initiate this exercise about
45 to 60 minutes later
and they would still have high blood
levels of insulin but then because of
all their muscle activity
there'd be an initial drop in glucose in
the blood
and what would happen was they would
experience hypoglycemic symptoms
and actually perform worse but we've
done a lot
a lot more research on that concept
since and it seems to vary substantially
from person to person some people are a
little bit sensitive to this
hypoglycemic effect at the onset of
exercise
some people really don't seem to
experience it much at all
and generally speaking the studies
looking at pre-workout carb
feeding i was going to say
supplementation but it's not necessarily
supplementation but this pre-exercise
carb feeding generally either has a
positive
or a neutral effect on performance
across a wide range of exercise
modalities and tasks but if you
if you do seem to get some hypoglycemic
symptoms if you have a high carb meal
in the meal prior to training there are
some strategies
that you can use to combat that and the
two
strategies that most people talk about
especially um
ask her you can droop i think that's how
he says the last name but i have no idea
um but he's like he's a really really
good sport nutrition researcher
who who does more in the endurance realm
and does a lot with carbohydrate
um his two strategies he he tends to
promote the most it seems are
go with a lower gi carb and potentially
even do it in like a mixed meal
to kind of make it a smoother gradual
rise in blood glucose and the insulin
response
or you can shift that carbohydrate
intake closer to the workout
and that seems to do the trick as well
so those are considerations to keep in
mind with that pre-workout meal
and finally one thing i haven't
mentioned yet is dietary fat
[Music]
with dietary fat a lot of times because
fat digests so slowly
a lot of people if they have a really
high fat meal before their workouts
the digestion is just too much for their
stomach to handle
their stomach hurts they get nauseous
during training they perform really
poorly
so if we're talking about a meal being
consumed within that hour before
training i usually tell people to keep
the fat to a minimum
um i'm really sensitive to that one time
i had back in my power lifting days i
had a huge meal of like uh
like i went to a restaurant that had
like uh buffalo wings
which are like just remarkably fatty and
then i tried to do like a high rep squat
work i think i was doing small odd at
the time
oh god i think i think i had like a
million sets of nine that day or
something
and i i just felt really bad it
didn't go well so so don't do that uh
some people are are totally fine with it
but i would say the average
the average stomach tends to be a little
sensitive to that immediately prior to
the workout so
like i said you know there are some some
specific instances where a person might
say
based on when i have to wake up based on
how my stomach reacts to having
any food in there i'm just gonna have to
go fasted
and it's it's not at all like oh well
sorry you wasted your workout you can
still do a fine workout with fasted
training
um i don't think it's the
purely optimal way to go about it but
there are certain cases where it beats
the alternative
of feeling sick your whole workout and
performing poorly but i think generally
speaking there are ways you can
accommodate that
that pre-exercise uh opportunity for
nutrient intake to get you
a slightly better outcome than training
fasted
no i i agree and one thing that i would
add is
like even if you don't have the time or
desire to
eat something before your workout i mean
during your workout itself you could
just sip along on gatorade instead of
water
absolutely and like that that would
still do something for you
especially like if energy levels are
potentially an issue yeah uh during the
workout you could go with
i mean any kind of sports beverage is
gonna be um
you know it's typically a five to eight
percent carbohydrate solution
generally speaking and yeah if you want
to you could even put some uh
some essential amino acids in there some
branched chain amino acids um
even some people like to put in
hydrolyzed protein
during the workout so so that that's
definitely another another good option